Hey youtubers it's Charlie, quick heads up,
I'm shooting this Q&A in my office because
I have to be in Hollywood for a movie screening
tonight but hopefully you've had a chance
to unpack last night's episode. There was
actually a lot of stuff happening, not just
the big fight between Oberyn Martell and the
Mountain. There were a lot of things I wasn't
able to fit in my video last night so as I
answer questions in this video I'll try to
work extra stuff in.
And if you didn't hear the news, Gwendoline
Christie who plays Brienne, is going to be
in Star Wars Episode 7. I'll talk about that
in my Star Wars video tomorrow.
Congratulations to Razz Ransom, you're this
week's winner of the giveaway. You win a $20
amazon gift card. I'll DM you on your channel
for details. If you're finding me for the
first time I do weekly giveaways just as a
way to say thank you to all you guys for being
awesome.
Question Time! I'll see if I can squeeze more
than I normally do in. Careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it. Question
1 - Thomas asks, what are Arya and The Hound
going to do now?
I think by the end of the season they'll do
their plot like it is in the books. For book
readers, please use the spoiler below the
fold method if you want to make specific references.
I was really happy when they started prolonging
their story, I think the two of them work
really well together. Loving characters on
Game of Thrones is dangerous though. You never
know who is going to die next. There's really
only two hours left in the season, but I fully
expect to see more Arya and Hound right up
until the finale.
Question 2 - Chris Todd asks Where's the Blackfish?
Yeah, we haven't seen him since his wedding
night...duh duh duh.
He's still alive, he's just a captive of the
Freys along with Greatjon Umber. I don't know
if we'll see him again before the end of the
season?
Question 3 - Jennie asks Will Arya and Sansa
meet
It really seemed like the show wanted us to
believe it might happen, but I think Arya
and the Hound will turn right around and go
somewhere else. As for Sansa and Littlefinger,
she said "Shall we go" and she dyed her hair
like in the books. So I think they'll be taking
Robyn on that big tour of his lands like he
was talking about with Yohn Royce.
Littlefinger really just wants to keep Robyn
under his thumb and it's harder to do that
when he's surrounded by palace guards. The
guards obey Robyn, not Littlefinger, so if
Robyn threw a tantrum and wanted to make people
fly, the guards would do it. Thus, Littlefinger
takes him away from the Moon Door.
Question 4 - Mamobster asks Isn't Cersei's
daughter still in Dorne, will this be bad
for her?
Prince Doran has a very cool head compared
to Oberyn and the Sand Snakes. Yes, people
are flipping out, just look at Ellaria's face.
This face is all of their faces. But they're
waiting till Season 5 to deal with a lot of
what actually ends up happening. So you'll
have to read book 4 and 5 if you don't want
to wait.
But I don't think the Martells would ever
hurt a child, Myrcella is engaged to Prince
Doran's son and Oberyn even said point blank
she was safe when Cersei and Tywin were up
in his face at the Purple Wedding.
It's not like Joffrey tormenting Sansa in
King's Landing. And just for reference, Myrcella
is younger than Sansa. If you look at her
in this picture though, it seems like the
show will age her up, just because the actress
who plays her is growing up so fast. That
happens with young actors like Tommen.
Question 5 - Jake Ashmore (no avatar) asks
what's going to happen to Tyrion now that
Oberyn is dead and is the Mountain Dead?
Technically Tyrion lost the trial by combat,
because Oberyn died before the Mountain. So
he's sentenced to death. Right after that
all went down he would have been escorted
back to the Black Cells to wait for Ilyn Payne
to chop his head off Ned Stark style.
The Mountain as far as we know is still alive
and is just gushing blood from all the pike
wounds. Part of the reason he's so hard to
kill is because he has such high body mass.
The weird thing about Game of Thrones is,
unless you see their head leave their body
or, their skull gets squished like a grape.
They're not dead. And if you're in the North,
because of White Walker Necromancy, you're
only confirmed dead if you get burned to ashes.
Question 6 - Ariadna asks did you think Daenerys
Over Reacted to Ser Jorah?
To be fair, most people probably would have
chopped his head off. She's just getting used
to being a queen and is really insecure. Hizdhar
and all the other slaving families are giving
her problems and the Wise Masters still need
to be dealt with. Plus she just came off of
the high she got from crucifying all those
people when she entered the city.
So combine insecurity with bloodlust and you
get murderous rage. Remember who her father
was, she's not like the mad king at all, but
I think her reaction was appropriate.
Once you catch someone lying, how can you
ever really know whether or not they're not
lying. So if Ser Jorah wants back in the trust
circle, he's going to have to do something
pretty epic.
Question 7 - Camille asks what happened between
Sansa and Baelish in her room after the camera
left?
I think he just left, I actually saw a bunch
of you wondering whether or not they had sex.
I don't think they did. In the books when
this was happening that wasn't the case, George
RR Martin spells it out more explicitly. I
think the show is just being more ambiguous
about it with those crazy long looks.
I think they just have an understanding now,
that she's not going to trust him, but she
trusts everyone else even less. So think of
them more as temporary allies. She needs all
the help she can get, and I think she senses
that Littlefinger isn't going to torture her
like the Lannisters.
Question 8 - Sergio asks what would have happened
if Jaime hadn't have lost his hand and fought
as Tyrion's Champion?
I don't think Tywin Lannister would have ever
permitted it to go down. He would have engineered
some plot to keep Jaime from stepping into
the ring. He's more than happy to be done
with Tyrion, but Jaime is still his prize.
But really if Jaime hadn't have lost his hand
everything that happened to him and Brienne
would have gone down differently.
I still think he would have kept Brienne safe,
but he wouldn't have been as open to turning
his life around. He would still be the asshole
he was before he lost his hand.
But there's no way he would have ever fought
the Mountain, even if he wanted to.
He did kill a person like the Mountain, he
was called the Smiling Knight. I talk about
it in that Top 10 Fighters video I posted
earlier. So technically I think he would have
had a shot against him in a fair fight.
Question 9 - Misti asks why is Stannis the
only one who's helping out at The Wall
Mostly because no one else takes it seriously,
or at least no one else with the power to
do something about it. But it's important
to remember that Stannis is the only person
that we've seen say he's going to help out.
That doesn't mean he'll be the only person
who ever helps with the White Walkers.
Because the show is going to last for about
8 seasons, I don't think it will get crazy
with White Walker battles until the last two.
So in the near future, it's just going to
be Stannis. If he doesn't make it to The Wall
at the end of this season, I think he'll get
there in the first episode of Season 5.
Question 10 - Inkheart asks was the simple
Lannister that squished the beetles in the
books?
Orson Lannister was not in the books, I think
that was Dan and Dave just trying to get all
existential. Like Tyrion is at the end of
his rope and he's pretty sure he's going to
die this time. See the crazy look on his face
while he was telling the story. He's a little
bit drunk, but he's completely out of his
mind and just wondering out loud, if there's
a reason for all the violence.
I know a lot of you thought it might just
be a metaphor for George RR Martin squishing
characters just because he can. To be fair,
I think it was a little of both. Both existential
and a wink to Martin.
Bonus Questions, here's a couple - Will the
Bolton's take Winterfell and rule in the North
and if Roose dies, does that mean Ramsay will
rule?
Yes, they don't need Winterfell the location
to be Wardens of the North, Roose is already
the ruler of the North in title. The reality
is that the North is so big, calling yourself
the ruler and all the people that live there
thinking you're their ruler are completely
different things. Roose is more like the Warden
of a clump of dirt in the North.
To answer your second question, yes, Ramsay
is a Bolton and his heir now. So everything
of Roose's will pass to him when he dies.
And last one, Ashley asks, was the Fight Scene
like it was in the books?
Pretty much, in the books thought the Mountain
punches Oberyn so hard his face breaks apart
and his eyes pop out of his skull. I don't
think he squished him. I think it was just
the punch that splattered him. But he did
get splattered.
The rest of the fight was the same as the
books, with him dancing around trying to get
the confession. The dialogue he said was lifted
directly from the page.
So, I hope everyone has a chance to rewatch
the episode this week just to add a little
more context after the shock wears off. Thanks
so much for submitting questions. These are
always fun to do. My next bonus video will
probably be for my favorite Prophecies. There's
a ton of them, so I might just do my top 10.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Also, since we've only got two more episodes
I want to start thinking about other shows
to do this summer. So here's where you can
really help me out. Either let me know in
the comments or on twitter or facebook whether
you just want Game of Thrones bonus videos
every sunday until Doctor Who comes back or
do you want me to try and work something I
haven't done in.
I'll still do bonus videos on a regular basis
regardless. But I'd like to try to find something
new and fun to do for the eight or so weeks
until Doctor Who comes and fills in the gap
where Game of Thrones videos would normally
happen.
I'll talk more about this when we get closer
to the finale. There's still a couple more
weeks and then all the Season 5 Bonus videos
will start.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my TOP 10 Fighters
alive or dead.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!